breaking overnight there is more trouble
for the hurricane ravaged Bahamas now
tropical storm
Umberto is threatening Grand Bahama
Island the new potential danger is
creating new worries for the more than
2,000 people living in shelters and
those trying to rebuild their homes
meteorologist Jeff bird Ellie is
tracking the storm Jeff good morning
good morning Dana and good morning to
all of you now we have some good news
with tropical storm
umberto winds you're only 40 miles an
hour and the worst of the storm take a
look to the east of the Abaco Islands by
about 50 miles so this could turn out to
be a decent situation for them very
limited impacts on Florida's east coast
as it takes more of a turn towards the
east we do have tropical storm warnings
out for the Bahamas but not Florida's
east coast you can see why at its
closest approach it's going to be at
least 150 to 200 miles to the east of
the Florida coast keeping the worst
impacts to the East now the system is
likely to be rushed out to sea watch out
Bermuda because as it moves your way
it's going to be a cat 1/2 or maybe even
low-end cat 3 hurricane here's a look at
the wind and the Gus and as you can see
the drier side of the storm just doesn't
have too much action passing breezy
showers wind gusts to 40 50 miles an
hour across the Bahamas maybe 35 40
miles an hour along Florida's east coast
places like Cape Canaveral the other big
story in the southeast is going to be
this big crashing waves along the coast
up to around 30 feet which means we're
gonna see some rough rough conditions on
the beaches and strong rip current risk
as well that's a look at your weather
forecast alright Jeff thank you very
much